WELL CABALLERO DOLLY HER TITLE
JONES LABOR. MCGUIRE MY NAME.
MORE LUCK PAN ROTH SKINNER
STERN. STONE. NUMBER BY KASKI
HERE. LABOR HERE. I'M SCROLLING.
IT HAPPENED IN THE. BUT FOR.
PERFECT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COLLEAGUES MADAM SECRETARY
NOTICES THE PRESENCE OF A
QUORUM IS MEMBERS CONTINUE TO
JOIN US THANK YOU SO MUCH
WELCOME TO TODAY'S SENATE
BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE
HEARING BEFORE WE GET STARTED I
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
PULLING AB ONE SEVENTEEN FROM
TODAY'S A GENDER WE EXPECT TO
HEAR IT LATER IN THE WEEK. THAT
LEAVES US WITH EIGHT BILLS WILL
BE HEARING TODAY A BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR AND SEVEN BUDGET TRAILER
BILLS AB ONE OH NINE ALSO KNOWN
AS BUDGET BILL JUNIOR IS OUR
TYPICAL CLEAN UP TO THE BUDGET
COLLEAGUES HOWEVER I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT IT ALSO INCLUDES A
HANDFUL OF NEW APPROPRIATIONS
THAT WERE EITHER PART OF THE
JUNE BUDGET NEGOTIATIONS OR
HAVE BEEN RECENTLY NEGOTIATED
WITH. THAT I'D LIKE TO WELCOME
MISTER THIS ONE OFTEN. BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE GOOD MORNING
MORNING AND THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BEFORE YOU GET
STARTED LET ME JUST ALSO
CLARIFY. THE NEXT SEE. THIS
BUDGET BILL JUNIORTAKES THREE
BASIC APPROACHES FIRST IT MAKES
AS THE CHAIR MENTIONED
TECHNICAL SUGGESTION TECHNICAL
UPDATES AND A FOLLOW UP TO THE
THREE PARTY AGREEMENT THAT WAS
REACHED IN JUNE AS WELL AS A
SMALL NUMBER OF ADDITIONAL
APPROPRIATIONS THAT FOLLOW ON
FROM THAT AGREEMENT THE SECOND
THING THAT IS IT DOES IS A
REFLECTS ANY CHANGES AND SHIFTS
IN FEDERAL FUNDING AVAILABILITY
AND THEN THE THIRD THING THAT
IT DOES IS IDENTIFY ANY
ADDITIONAL TRAILER BILLS AS
PART OF THAT BUT YOU DON'T
CLEAN UP PROCESS. SO THEIR
NUMBER OF TECHNICAL ELEMENTS IN
THE BILL BUT I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE MORE
SUBSTANTIVE PROVISIONS FIRST
FOR THE CALVET PROGRAM THIS IS
THE CALIFORNIA VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION PREVENTION
PROGRAMS IN THE BUDGET
AGREEMENT WE AT THE GOVERNMENT
INCREASED FUNDING FROM NINE
MILLION DOLLARS TO THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR WHAT IS NOW
THE CURRENT YEAR THIS WOULD
RAISE THE CAP ON THE SIZE OF
ANY INDIVIDUAL GRANT FROM HALF
A MILLION DOLLARS TO ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. IT ALSO
INCLUDES YOUR PREPARATION OF
TWO HUNDRED SIX MILLION DOLLARS
IN BONDS FUNDING FOR SONGS
SALTON SEA HABITAT RESTORATION
MUCH OF THAT REVERTED FROM THE
PRIOR YEAR APPROPRIATIONS THIS
WILL ENABLE AN EARLIER START TO
THAT PROJECT AS MENTIONED WITH
REGARD TO FEDERAL FUNDS CHANGES
WITH REGARD TO THE MIGRANT
EDUCATION PROGRAM AS WELL AS
THE MCKINNEY VENTO HOMELESS
CHILDREN COLLEGE EDUCATION
PROGRAM AS WELL AS CHEFS AND
AVAILABILITY OF FEDERAL FUNDING
FOR CAL WORKS AND FINALLY AND
NOT HAVE CITY AND- AROUND SAYS
THE CHAIR MENTIONED SMALL
APPROPRIATIONS AND BEYOND THAT
RE APPROPRIATIONS OF FUNDING
THAT WAS NOT EXPENDED IN PRIOR
YEARS. HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS
ON ANY OF THESE ELEMENTS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY QUESTIONS. ON
AB ONE OH NINE BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR. KABIR THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I JUST HAVE A REAL QUICK
QUESTION THE COPY I P. I GUESS
I MISSED THAT ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS THE INCREASE
ONE OF THE ONE OF THE PIECES
THAT WAS VERY IMPORTANT TO ME
IN THE CAL VIP PROGRAM IS THAT
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THAT IT'S
SET UP AND THIS IS REALLY TO
REDUCE GANG VIOLENCE IN IN IN
OUR COMMUNITIES MANY RURAL
ISOLATED COMMUNITIES HAVE THE
SAME GAME VIOLENCE ISSUE THAT
THE BIG CITIES DO AND SO WE DID
A CARVE OUT FOR COMMUNITIES OF
LESSEN FORD FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FORTY THOUSAND
INHABITANTS. IN AN EFFORT TO
TRY TO GET RESOURCES INTO SOME
OF THOSE COMMUNITIES AND IF YOU
MAKE THE GRANTS TO BIG THEN
THERE'S LESS MONEY TO GO AROUND
AND MOST OF THESE COMMUNITIES
DON'T REALLY NEED ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN A GRANT
THEY JUST A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS MAKES A HUGE DIFFERENCE
SO I I'M I'M WONDERING IF YOU
COULD TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
THAT I MEAN A MY CONCERN IS IT
GOES UP TO MOST OF THE BIG
CITIES AND IN THE PAST THAT'S
BEEN FINE WITH ME BECAUSE
SALINAS HAS BEEN CONSIDERED ONE
OF THE BIG CITIES BUT I NOW
HAVE TWENTY SEVEN CITIES THAT
ARE SMALLER THAN THAT AND SO IF
YOU COULD ADDRESS THAT PLEASE
MAKE TWO QUICK POINTS AND ALSO
TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
HERE AND THE FIRST IS THAT I
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT AND
THAT WAS ONE REASON WHILE THE
CAP IS INCREASED. WE DID NOT
SOME PEOPLE LIKE TO JUST
REMOVING CAP ALTOGETHER AND FOR
EXACT CONCERNS THAT YOU
MENTIONED WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS A CAP THAT IS
MEANINGFUL THE SECOND POINT IS
THAT IN THE CONTEXT OF A THREE
MILLION DOLLAR PROGRAMS RATHER
THAN A NINE MILLION DOLLAR
PROGRAMS WE THOUGHT THAT IT
PRISON THE CAP IS NOT GIVE SOME
FLEXIBILITY TO THE BIG CITIES
WHILE ALSO MAINTAINING
RESOURCES FOR STATE FOR
PROGRAMS IN ALL DIFFERENT AREAS
OF THE STATE AND THEN THE THIRD
POINT I WOULD MENTION IS FOR
SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS IT TAKES
SEVERAL YEARS TO REALLY GAUGE
THE- EFFECTIVENESS SO HAVING
THIS LARGER AMOUNT BUT SPREAD
OVER A NUMBER OF YEARS. MIGHT
ENABLE US TO DO THAT. I'LL TURN
IT OVER TO MISTER EDWARDS. ERIN
EDWARDS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SO JUST WHAT AT TWO OF MY
COLLEAGUE SAID BY NOTING THAT.
I THINK IN THE PAST THE BORDERS
STAY IN COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
ALLOCATING THESE GROUNDS. HAS
THEY'VE NOTED THAT THE THERE
HAVE BEEN A RELUCTANCE ON ON
THE PART OF SOME. WELL HOW IT
IS TO APPLY FOR THE FOR THESE
GRANTS BECAUSE OF THE FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR CAP.
GIVEN THE NUMBER OF
ADMINISTRATIVE REQUIREMENTS ON
REPORTING ON THESE GRANTS. I
THINK IT HAS DISSUADED SOME
SOME LOCALS FROM FROM APPLYING
I THINK. THEIR ANTICIPATION IS
THAT BY RAISING THAT CAP TO ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION IS GOING TO
OPEN UP. APPLICATION STATE TO
CUT. LOCALITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
RELUCTANT TO APPLY IN THE PAST.
YEAH YES I GUESS I BACK I JUST
WANT TO PUT IS A FOOTNOTE TO
THAT I APPRECIATE THAT
EXPLANATION THANK YOU. IS THAT
IT'S NOT THE SMALLER
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE RELUCTANT
TO APPLY IT IT'S A BIGGER
CITIES WHO HAVE MORE RESOURCES
AND THEY LOOK AT IT AND THEY
SAY WE GOT ENOUGH MONEY TO DEAL
WITH THIS SO. WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GO THROUGH THE STATE GRANT
PROCESS SO I I'LL JUST LEAVE IT
AT THAT AND TELL YOU THAT THIS
IS. I THINK A REAL IMPORTANT
RESOURCE. THAT HAS BEEN
UNAVAILABLE TO SMALLER
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE THEY JUST
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO DO
THE GRANT AND THEN TO FOLLOW
THROUGH. AND THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO COMPETE BASED ON THAT
THAT ANALYSIS THAT YOU HAVE TO
HAVE HI VIOLENCE IN YOUR
COMMUNITY IF YOU THEY DO BUT IN
COMPARISON TO THE BIG CITIES
THEY CAN'T MAKE IT SO. THAT'S
WHY THAT'S IMPORTANT FALL
CONVERSATION HAPPEN. TO BE A C.
C. AS WELL. YES THE SHEET THAT.
THANK YOU IN FOR THE QUESTIONS.
THE NON PUBLIC COMMENT ON AB
ONE OH NINE. GOOD MORNING KYLE
HIGHLANDER BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA CAN
CAN IN COLLEGE ADMINISTRATORS
HERE TO SUPPORT THE A PROVISION
IN AB ONE OH NINE THAT WOULD
ELIMINATE THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT LOCAL MATCH
REQUIREMENT FROM THE CAL WORKS
PROGRAM. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR JENNIFER FEARING
FIRST ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
WILD HORSE CAMPAIGN I WANTED TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
FUNDING. TO BE ALLOCATED TO THE
WILD HORSE MANAGEMENT A- TOOL
FOR UC DAVIS SCHOOL OF
VETERINARY MEDICINE. AND ALSO
ON BEHALF OF DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO
SEE THE INCREASE FUNDING FOR
AWHILE OF HABITAT. PROTECTION
THE SALTON SEA URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MATT ROBINSON WAS SHOT
YOUR AND THREE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA GREEN BUSINESS
PROGRAM. WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE ALLOCATION IT'S
MADE IN THIS BILL IS TO BE THE
THIRD YEAR IN A ROW THE
LEGISLATURE HAS GRANTED US
FUNDING IN ORDER TO KEEP THE
PROGRAM GOING SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. YOU
MERE MORTON HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION AND JUST
WANTED TO SUPPORT THE
CLARIFYING LANGUAGE RELATED TO
PEDIATRIC GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RATTLE HAGER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE TWEAK. IN
LANGUAGE OF THE PRIMARY CARE.
AS A COUNTRY SCHOLARSHIPS THAT
DOES ALLOW US TO TREAT OUR
OFFER. SCHOLARSHIPS TO NON
PHYSICIANS AS WELL AS
PHYSICIANS AND THAT'S VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BOB MADAM CHAIR MY CAL WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY BUT WE ALSO ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE OF REPEAL OR
THE REMOVAL OF THE TOWERS MATCH
LANGUAGE WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE. TAKING THAT
INCLUDING IN THE BILL THANK YOU.
WHERE'S THE FLOORS OF THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
AND WE ARE IN OPPOSITION WITH
THE ADDITIONAL TEN MILLION
DOLLARS. THAT WILL GO TO
ALLOCATE FOR NONPROFIT SAID
DODD. DEAL WITH ABORTION
SERVICES. AND THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
WITHOUT LIMITING THE MOTION.
SECOND. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB
ONE IN NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS MITCHELL HI WELL I NIELSEN
NIELSEN NOBEL WELL I HAVE A
HERO CAREER ON A DOLLY THE ONLY
KNOWN HER DAUGHTER HER TOTAL
AYE JONES LEYVA. LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE. WHERE I AM MONEY MONEY
NINE MORE LAW. PAN I ROTH ROTH
AYE SKINNER AYE SKINNER AYE
STERN TERN AYE STONE AMBER.
AMBER GUYS WHY BECAUSE HE WHY
BECAUSE THE AYE. WE'RE GONNA
HOLD THAT ITEM OPEN. THANK YOU
WILL BE ON COLLEAGUES TO AB. AB
ONE TWELVE IS THE TRAILER BILL
ON STATE IN GENERAL GOVERNMENT
AND HAS A COUPLE OF KEY
PROVISIONS THE FIRST RELATES TO
THE OFFICE OF DIGITAL
INNOVATION THIS WAS AN OFFICE
THAT WAS CREATED IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT A COUPLE
MONTHS AGO THIS BILL BASICALLY
TAKES STEPS TO ENSURE THAT THE
DATA PROVIDED TO THAT OFFICE
REMAINS CONFIDENTIAL AND ALSO
REQUIRES REPORTING FROM THAT
OFFICE TO THE LEGISLATURE ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS. SECOND WITH
REGARD TO THE CAL SAVERS
PROGRAM FORMALLY KNOWN AS THE
SECURE CHOICE PROGRAM THIS
ELIMINATES WHAT'S KNOWN AS THE
GAME LOS ACCOUNT WHICH WAS USED
FOR SMOOTHING AND THAT ACCOUNT
IS NOT BEING USED BY THE
PROGRAM IN ANY CASE SO THIS
BASICALLY TEXT EDITORIAL WAY.
THIRD THING THAT THIS TRAILER
BILL DOES IS IT CLARIFIES THE
USE OF THE PDSA THAT'S THE
BUDGET DEFICIT SAVINGS ACCOUNT
IT ALSO MAKES A NUMBER OF
TECHNICAL CHANGES BUT FINALLY
THREE SUBSTANTIVE AREAS THAT
YOU WANT TO HIGHLIGHT. FIRST IS
THAT CLARIFIES EXISTING LAW
WITH REGARD TO EMPLOYMENT
VERIFICATION BY EMPLOYERS
SECOND IS AN AGREEMENT ON A
VEHICLE EXHAUST IN TERMS OF
NOISE STANDARDS WITH REGARD TO
CARS VERSUS MOTORCYCLES AND WE
KNOW THAT'S BEEN UP FOR A
PRODUCT OF A NUMBER OF
CONVERSATIONS AMONGST MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND THEN THE
THIRD IS WITH REGARD TO THE
OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
THIS ENABLES DISCRETIONARY
SIERRA AUDITING VIEWS OF CDC
ARE WITHOUT PRIOR APPROVAL FROM
THE LEGISLATURE OR THE GOVERNOR
AND TAKES A THREE AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLAR APPROPRIATION
FROM A PRIOR BILL AND CLARIFIES
HOW CAN BE USED TWENTY ONE
POSITIONS AND I DO WANT TO MAKE
ONE LAST POINT ON THIS WHICH IS
THAT WE KNOW THAT THERE HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSIONS WITH KEY
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE ON
PEACE OFFICER STATUS. WITHIN
THIS OFFICE THAT'S A
CONVERSATION THE ADMINISTRATION
IS COMMITTED TO CONTINUING OVER
THE NEXT COUPLE. MONTHS AND ONE
OF REACH SOME TYPE OF
RESOLUTION ON THAT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE HOPE TO REACH
RESOLUTION THAT'LL CENTER THE
NEXT COUPLE MONTHS BUT THANK
YOU FOR THAT. COMMENT ANY
QUESTIONS SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND A
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION
AND APPRECIATE THAT THE BILL
BEFORE US DOES HAVE THE
LANGUAGE IN RELATIONSHIP TO THE
OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL
AROUND THE AUDITS AND SUCH AND
WHICH IS GREAT NOW THE ISSUE
THAT YOU REFERENCED WHICH I
APPRECIATE ALSO THAT THERE ARE
DISCUSSIONS UNDERWAY AROUND THE
PEACE OFFICER STATUS. I JUST
WANT TO GIVE A LITTLE CONTEXT
BECAUSE EVEN EVEN I WHO VOTED
IN TWENTY ELEVEN TO ELIMINATE
PEACE OFFICERS FROM THE OFFICE
OF INSPECTOR GENERAL I THINK.
DIDN'T FULLY APPRECIATE HOW.
WHAT THE IMPACT OF THAT ACTION
WOULD BE IN TERMS OF THAT
OFFICE BEING ABLE TO HAVE THE
TYPE OF INVESTIGATORY AUTHORITY
THAT WHENWE LOOK AT THE
ESTABLISHMENT THE LEGISLATURE'S
ESTABLISHMENT OF THAT OFFICE IN
WHAT THE PURPOSE WAS IT WAS TO
HAVE. WITHIN OUR LARGEST STATE
DEPARTMENT WITH THE LARGEST
NUMBER OF STATE EMPLOYEES TO
HAVE A SEMI INDEPENDENT I SAY
SEMI BECAUSE IT'S STILL A STATE
AGENCY. ENTITY THAT COULD.
INVOLVE ITSELF OVERSEE
COMPLAINTS AND SUCH AND INVOLVE
ITSELF IN THAT PROCESS TO A
DEGREE NOW WE'VE PUT BELTS AND
SUSPENDERS ON HOW THAT OFFICE
CAN BE INVOLVED IN SUCH
INVESTIGATIONS WHICH I
APPRECIATE AND DON'T WANT
NECESSARILY FOR US TO UNDO. THE
REMAINING ISSUE AROUND THE LACK
OF A PEACE OFFICER WITH IN THAT
UNIT IS THAT IT. IT PUTS THE
UNIT IN A POSITION WHERE IT
CANNOT HANDLE OR PROCESS
EVIDENCE BECAUSE OUR CODES
REQUIRED THE US PEACE OFFICER
STATUS TO DO SO. AND THUS IF
THERE IS AN INVESTIGATION WHERE.
WHERE SUCH EVIDENCE IS RELEVANT
IT ALSO CANNOT OF. PROCESS SEND
THAT EVIDENCE TO SAY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FOR ANY
TYPE OF PROCESSING SO YET CHAIN
OF CUSTODY YES THANK YOU ARE
NOT BEING A LAWYER I DON'T KNOW
ALL THE TERMS ANYWAY SO THAT'S
REALLY WHAT FROM I THINK OUR
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEES POINT OF
VIEW WHAT WE WERE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE AND I THINK WHAT
HAPPENED IN OUR DISCUSSIONS IS
THAT. WE AS A LEGISLATURE
APPROVED A BUDGET THAT HAD
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION FOR
THE OFFICE WHICH IS GREAT AND
IS REFLECTED HERE AND I THINK
IN THE INTERIM DISCUSSIONS AS
TO HOW THAT WOULD BE ALLOCATED
IT WAS VIEWED THAT. THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A PEACE
OFFICER WOULD NEED ADDITIONAL
FUNDS OVER AND ABOVE THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION AND I THINK
THAT WHAT WE DIDN'T REALLY
FACTOR IS THE FACT THAT THERE
ARE EXISTING STAFF WITH IN THAT
UNIT WHO HAD PREVIOUSLY BEEN
SWORN PEACE OFFICERS SO THAT WE
MAY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RESTORE ONE FOR EXAMPLE. AT A
MUCH LOWER COST AND WITHOUT
HAVING TO CREATE A NEW POSITION
AND THAT'S CERTAINLY I THINK
WHAT PART OF WHAT WE ARE
DISCUSSING SO I JUST WANTED TO
EXPRESS THAT APPRECIATE THAT
THE DISCUSSION. OF EIGHT AND
HOPE THAT WE CAN TO RESOLUTION.
HERE HERE THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. I CASKEY
LET ME BE MORE FRANK INTERACT
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY
ST THIS CAN BE FIXED MINISTRY
TO PLAY WE SHOULDN'T BE
HARBORING BAD ACT ACTIVITY IN
BAD ACTIONS THEY'RE GOING ON IN
OUR IN OUR STATE PRISONS WE
EXPECT AS AT LEAST I AS A
MEMBER THIS BUT BUDGET
COMMITTEE EXPECT THE
MINISTRATION TO FIX IT. THIS
CAN BE DONE WE DON'T NEED TO
LEGISLATE IT. THANK WITH THAT
ON MOVE THE MATTER THANK YOU
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE. MADAM
CHAIR MY CAR WITH WESTERN
CENTER LAW POVERTY WE'RE HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE TO A
RESTORE WHEN SOMEONE HAS A LOUD
MUFFLER TO GET A FIX THE TICKET
RATHER THAN A TICKET WHICH IS A
BURDEN ON OUR CLIENTS IN
SOMETHING WE ARE HOPE WOULD GET
FIX THIS YEAR WERE VERY GLAD TO
SEE IT. IN THIS TRAILER BILL
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CAROLING ABOUT OF THE SPECIALTY
EQUIPMENT MARKET ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE- MUFFLER
FIXED. OF THIS THEME A
REPRESENTS ABOUT SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING. MY FOR
MANUFACTURERS BORLAND MAGNAFLOW
AND THEY'RE GRATEFUL TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR TAKING THIS ON.
AND YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING
THERE AND WE ARE DRY SUPPORTING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SEE NO FOR
THE CAR A PUBLIC COMMENT WE'VE
HAD A MOTION PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL FROM MR AYE CASKEY PLEASE
BE ONE TWELVE MOTION IS TO PASS
MITCHELL. HI JILL AYE NIELSEN.
WELL. CORRECT WELL I CABALLERO
CAREER AYE DOLLY THE ONLY KNOW
HER TAUGHT OF HER TOTAL I'D
JONES LEYVA LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE ONLINE MONEY MONEY NINE
MORE LOCK PAN PAN AYE ROTH AYE
SKINNER SKINNER AYE STERN STERN
AYE STONE NUMBER. NUMBER NINE
WHITE HUSKY BECAUSE THE AYE
YES NO. TENER NIELSEN YES TO
KNOW DIDN'T VOTE LEE WAS NON
VOTING TO NOW SO IT'S ENOUGH.
WELL HOLD THAT ITEM OPEN I
THINK WE STILL HAVE SOME OF THE
MEMBERS WHO HAVE BEEN JOINED IS
MOVING ON TO ITEM THREE ON THE
AGENDA A. B. THIRTEEN HOUSING.
FINANCE. AB ONE THIRTEEN IS THE
HOUSING. AB ONE THIRTEEN IS THE
HOUSING TRAILER BILL TWO MAJOR
ELEMENTS HERE FIRST THIS REGARD
TODAY NATIONAL MORTGAGE
SETTLEMENT SO THIS WAS THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WAS REQUIRED BY
THE COURT TO BE RE APPROPRIATED
FOR SPECIFIED PURPOSES SO THIS
BILL ESTABLISHES THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT TO CREATE A
PERMANENT TRUST WITH THAT THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS TO ASSIST PEOPLE WHO
ARE. IN DANGER OF FORECLOSURE
HELPING PREVENT FORECLOSURES AS
WELL AS HELPING RENTERS AND
RENTER AN EVICTION PROTECTION
RELATED MATTERS SO THIS WOULD
BE AN ON GOING UP PERMANENT
SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR THESE
MATTERS THE BILL INCLUDES A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
PREPARATION FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TO STUDY THE BEST
WAY OF ADMINISTERING THIS TRUST
AND THE INTENT IS TO CREATE THE
TRUST BY JUNE THIRTIETH OF NEXT
YEAR. THE OTHER ELEMENT OF THIS
BILL ARE NUMBER OF TECHNICAL
CHANGES AND FIXES WITH REGARD
TO THE HOUSING PLANNING AND
PRODUCTION LANGUAGE SHOULD THAT
WAS ENACTED IN JUNE THIS
INCLUDES TIMELINE CHANGES FOR
NOTICE AND FINDINGS OF ANY
VIOLATIONS AS WELL AS
CLARIFICATION OF ANY REMEDIES
INCLUDING HOW THEY RELATE TO
THE REMEDIES AB SEVENTY TWO
THAT WAS ENACTED A COUPLE YEARS
AGO. AND THEN FINALLY WITH A
CART TO COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS
IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS ENABLING
THEM TO ACCESS UP 225% OF THE
AVAILABLE PLANNING PRODUCTION
FUNDING FOR THEIR SIX CYCLE
RENO GOALS AND HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. ON ANY OF THESE
ELEMENTS THANK YOU FOR THAT ANY
QUESTIONS. ANY QUESTIONS THIRTY
NIELSEN. COULD YOU A- INDICATE
HOW THE STRESSED IS GOING TO
ACTUALLY BE IMPLEMENTED AND
FORCED. ORGANIZE MONITORED. SO
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF OPTIONS
AVAILABLE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IS STUDYING THE
GENERAL OUTLINE IS THAT THE
REASON WOULD BE TRANSFERRED TO
A NONPROFIT TRIES TO SAID THAT
THAT TRUST CAN BURN A
SUFFICIENT RATE OF RETURN ON
THOSE INVESTMENTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE FUNDING CAN EXIST IN
PERPETUITY AND A NONPROFIT CAN
INVEST THOSE FUNDS IN A MATTER
THAT IS DIFFERENT FROM THE
STATE GOVERNMENT WHILE STILL
ENSURING THAT ITS INVESTMENT
MATTER THAT STATION PRUDENT BUT
ALSO GAINS THAT RATE OF RETURN
WHERE YOU CAN USE THE MONEY
YEAR OVER YEAR IN A WAY THAT'S
MORE SIGNIFICANT THAN IF THE
MONEY WERE KEPT WITHIN THE
STATE. AT THE SAME TIME TO YOUR
POINT THE ADMINISTRATION DOES
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
SUFFICIENT OVERSIGHTS OF THE
OVERSIGHT OF FINES BOTH IN
TERMS OF ITS COMPLIANCE WITH
THE NATIONAL MORTGAGE
SETTLEMENT AND ALSO TO ENSURE
THAT USED EFFECTIVELY SO THE
TWO MAJOR PURPOSES WE'VE
IDENTIFIED THAT ARE CONSISTENT
WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
INSTRUCTIONS AND NOT SETTLEMENT
ARE NUMBER ONE HELPING PREVENT
FORECLOSURES AND NUMBER TWO
REALLY FOR RENTERS AND LEGAL
AID FOR THEM AS THEY ARE GOING
THROUGH THESE PROCEEDINGS BUT
THAT IS AN ISSUE WHEN IT COMES
TO THE DETAIL THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WANTS TO
STUDY. AND WANTS TO BE INTO
OPTIONS WILL OF COURSE REQUIRE
FURTHER ACTION FROM THE
LEGISLATURE BEFORE EVERYTHING
IS CREATED AND GETS GOING HOW
CLEAR IS THE LEGISLATIVE HOURS
THE STORY HERE IT WOULD APPEAR.
THE ADMINISTRATION CARRIES MOST
OF THE AUTHORITY. IN OVERSEEING
THIS TRUST. TO THE LEGISLATURE
DOES HAVE TO APPROPRIATE THE
MONEY. AND AS PART OF THAT THAT
WOULD BE AN ONGOING DISCUSSION
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION ON HOW
THAT WOULD BE APPROPRIATED
INCLUDING THE DESIGN OF ANY
OVERSIGHT MECHANISMS FOR THAT
MONEY. BUT THE ADMINISTRATION
COULD MAKE OBLIGATIONS. IT
WOULD PUT PRESSURE ON THE
LEGISLATURE TO HAVE TO GO ALONG
WITH THAT NOT BE THE CASE.
ULTIMATELY THE FIGHT THE FINAL
BILL GOVERNING HOW THIS MONEY
IS USED WOULD HAVE TO BE PASSED
BY THE LEGISLATURE. BUT IT DOES
GIVE FRONT END PRESSURE I THINK.
CERTAINLY THE GOVERNOR AND THE
ADMINISTRATION HAVE A VIEW ON
HOW THE MONEY SHOULD BE SPENT
IN THAT WAS THE GOVERNOR
RELEASED PROPOSAL ALONG THESE
LINES ABOUT A MONTH AGO. BUT IT
WAS IN CONCERT WITH DISCUSSIONS
WITH MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
AND THOSE DISCUSSIONS WILL BE
ON GOING THIS PROCESS IS.
DEFINITELY NOT COMPLETE BILL IS
CHAPTER THEN WHAT HAPPENS NEXT.
SO THIS BILL ESTABLISHES THE
INTENT LANGUAGE THE MONEY IS
TRANSFERRED INTO THIS ACCOUNT
AND THEN IF THIS BILL IS PASSED
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE HAS IN
PREPARATION TO STUDY FURTHER
OPTIONS FOR EXACTLY WHAT THE
OVERSIGHT MECHANISM IS AND HOW
EXACTLY THE MONEY WILL BE USED.
BUT IT WILL TAKE FURTHER
LEGISLATIVE ACTION NEXT YEAR
BEFORE ANY OF THESE FUNDS CAN
BE TRANSFERRED TO A NON PROFIT
OR BEFORE ANY BOARD IS
ESTABLISHED WITH APPOINTMENTS
OVERSEEING THE USE OF THOSE
FUNDS IN THAT NONPROFIT OR WITH
REGARD TO HOW THESE FUNDS ARE
ACTUALLY DISPERSED ALL OF THAT
WILL TAKE ADDITIONAL. ACTION.
THAT WOULD BE BUDGET ACTION
TRAILER BILL ACTION. BUT WHAT
FORM YES IT WOULD BE WOULD BE
CERTAINLY LEGISLATIVE ACTION IN
SOME FORM WITH REGARD TO BE
EXACT VEHICLE UP BEAT OUT BE
DISCUSSIONS WITH MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE. AND WHAT AGAIN IT
WOULD BE THE- THE REASON FOR.
ESTABLISHING THE- SETTLEMENT
TRUST. WHAT WHAT IS THE
ADMINISTRATION TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH BY THIS METHOD. YES
SO WHEN IT COMES TO THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THIS FOLLOWS ON WHAT THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION ON HAD
BEEN. PURSUING A COURT CASE
WITH REGARD TO THE USE THAT
MONEY BECAUSE THE LEGISLATURE
HAD PREVIOUSLY APPROPRIATED
SEVERAL YEARS AGO. AND GOVERNOR
BROWN HAD SIGNED DIFFERENT USE
OF THAT MONEY FOR THOSE FINES.
THAT WAS REJECTED BY THE COURT
AND THE COURT SAID THE MONEY
HAS TO BE RE PROCREATIVE IN
LINE WITH THE SETTLEMENT
INSTRUCTIONS. SO THERE ARE MANY
WAYS IN WHICH YOU CAN USE THAT
MONEY WITH REGARD TO THE
SETTLEMENT INSTRUCTIONS
ALTHOUGH IT IS STILL A-
RELATIVELY SERVICE
CIRCUMSCRIBED UNIVERSE. AND
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION
BELIEVED IN WHAT WE HOPE D. F.
FITS WITH WHAT LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES ARE IS THAT RATHER
THAN USING IT ON A ONE TIME
BASIS AND SAYING THERE'S THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS. WHAT SPEND IT ON A OR
D. ON A ONE YEAR OR THREE YEAR
BASIS AND IT'S TIME WHY DON'T
WE CREATE AN ON GOING PERMANENT
SOURCE OF FUNDING AND PART OF
THAT WAS INSPIRED BY. WHAT
OCCURRED AND THE ENACTMENT OF
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET WHERE THERE
WAS AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS ON A ONE TIME
BASIS FOR A RENTER PROTECTIONS
MONEY THAT FLOW THROUGH THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. AND THE
ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES THAT
WITH APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT
PROGRAMS LIKE THAT CAN BE VERY
EFFECTIVE AND WE WOULD BE VERY
USEFUL IF RATHER THAN THAT
BEING SUBJECT TO THE VAGARIES
OF THE BUDGET PROCESS. THERE.
WERE A PERMANENT SOURCE OF
FUNDING THAT WILL BE AVAILABLE
YEAR OVER YEAR. WITH THE
ASSUMPTION HERE IS THAT THE-
MONEY WILL BE MADE AND AS YOU
INDICATED FOR THE WE DID A
CRUCIAL MONEY AND WAS ABLE TO
BE DIRECTED TOWARDS A- AND IDEA
PROGRAM. WELL THE INVESTMENT
COULD GO BAD AS WELL WHAT
HAPPENS IN THAT CASE CITIES ARE
THE DETAILS THAT HAVE TO BE
WORKED OUT ITS WHY THE PROGRAM
IS NOT BEING ESTABLISHED RIGHT
NOW BUT CERTAINLY AS PART OF
ANY MACINNES OVERSIGHT
MECHANISMS HE WOULD HAVE TO
CREATE AN INVESTMENT POLICY
SIMILAR TO YOU KNOW HOW OTHER
BIG ANNOUNCEMENTS ARE PENSION
FUNDS ARE RAIMES WHEN HE
RETURNED IS NOT WHAT YOU EXPECT
TO HAVE TO CONSIDER HOW YOU
MIGHT REACT TO THAT SO THOSE
ARE ALL ELEMENTS WHERE THEY'RE
BEING OVERSIGHT BOARD THERE'D
BE AN INVESTMENT COMMITTEE OR
PERSON RESPONSIBLE WITH
OVERSIGHT FROM THAT. APPOINTEES
TO THAT BOARD AND SO THAT'S
SOMETHING WHERE TO USE AT A
SLIGHTLY LOWER RATE OF RETURN
EXPECTED ON YOUR IN TERMS YEAR
PAY OUT AND THEN WITH THE UPS
AND DOWNS OF THE MARKET NOT
HAVE TO ADJUST FOR YOU SET UP
HIGHER AND PERHAPS THAT MORE
AVERAGE EXPECTED RATE OF RETURN
AND THEN WHEN IT DOES GO LOW
FOR A PERIOD OF TIME AS WE SAW
IN THE GREAT RECESSION YOU
REDUCE YOUR PAY OUT TO SOME OF
THESE NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
THAT SOMETHING THAT HAS TO BE
WORKED OUT AND IT'S WHY
REQUIRES ADDITIONAL STUDY
BECAUSE THAT IS A- QUESTION
THAT IS THERE IS NO SIMPLE
ANSWER TO THAT. WELL. IT
APPEARS A LITTLE BIT TOO VAGUE
AND DYNAMIC. TO SUIT ME I'VE
I'M NOT COMFORTABLE ENOUGH AT
THIS POINT. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS. PUBLIC
COMMENT. SEE NONE WE'VE HAD A
MOTION PLEASE CALL THE ROLL IF
YOU WANT THIRTEEN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS MITCHELL DIED JULY
NIELSEN WE ALSO KNOW WELL BILL
AYE CARREIRO. CAREER AYE DOLLY.
HER DAUGHTER HER TOTAL AYE
JONES JONES NO LEYVA. LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE MINING MONEY NINE MORE
LOCK PAN. PAN AYE ROTH ROTH AYE
SKINNER ALL RIGHT SKINNER AYE
STERN STERN AYE STONE NUMBER.
NUMBER GUY WAY BECAUSE HE HAS
THE AYE. WE'RE GONNA HOLD ITEM
OPEN MOVING ON TO THE FOURTH
ITEM ON THE AGENDA AB ONE
FOURTEEN EDUCATION FINANCE. AB
ONE FOURTEEN EDUCATION TRAILER
BILL THIS BILL MAKES A NUMBER
OF TECHNICAL CHANGES ONE IS
WITH REGARD TO THE SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS TO CALPERS AND CAL
STARS ON BEHALF OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. THIS BILL CLARIFIES
THAT THOSE PAYMENTS DO NOT
COUNT WITH REGARD TO THE
ROUTINE RESTRICTING MEETINGS
MAINTENANCE REQUIREMENTS THAT
ARE IMPOSED ON SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THIS IS WITH REGARD TO THE
FACILITIES BOND PROGRAMS AND
BECAUSE OF THESE PAYMENTS CAME
AT THE END OF THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET
YEAR. THIS BILL CLARIFIES TO
ADD THESE PAYMENTS FROM THE
STATE TO NOT MAKE ANY CHANGES
WITH REGARD TO SCHOOLS EXISTING
REQUIREMENTS TO COMPLY WITH
THEIR BOND PROGRAMS SO VERY
TECHNICAL BUT IMPORTANT CHANGE
IN ADDITION THIS BILL INCLUDES
SOME SHIPS WITH REGARD TO.
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
SETTLED FUNDING ALSO TECHNICAL
CHANGES A SMALL SHIPS IN THE
BILL ABILITY A FEDERAL FUNDS
AND THEN FINALLY TO MORE
SUBSTANTIVE AREAS I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT FIRST IS A DATE
SHIFTED AWAY IN TERMS OF THE
ETHNIC STUDIES CURRICULUM WHEN
THAT IS READY AND THAT OF
COURSE HAS BEEN. CONVERSATION
WITH MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
AND LEGISLATIVE STAFF AND
SECOND A CLARIFICATION OF THE
CHILD SAVINGS ACCOUNT PROGRAM
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED IN THE
BUDGET ACT THIS WILL MAKE CLEAR
THAT THOSE ACCOUNTS ARE
AVAILABLE AT TO ALL CHILDREN.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS MEMBERS. WE
HAVE A SENATOR NIELSEN. AN
ISSUE REGARDING THE ETHNIC
STUDIES CORRECT. WHAT WHY IS
THE THERE A NEED FOR. CHANGING
THE DEADLINE ARE WE BEHIND OUR
WE HAVE THINGS THAT YOU HAVE
NOT YET ACCOMPLISHED. IS IT.
WHAT WHAT'S THE LADY OR THE
NEED SO I BELIEVE THAT
ACCORDING TO THE LAW THAT WAS
ENACTED I THINK IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN THERE HAD TO BE
ADOPTION OF THAT CURRICULUM BY
THE BOARD BY MARCH THIRTY FIRST
OF NEXT YEAR. AND SO I THINK
AFTER THE EVENTS OF THE LAST
COUPLE WEEKS IN DISCUSSIONS
OVER SOME OF THE TRAPS PEOPLE
RECOGNIZE THAT WE NEED
ADDITIONAL TIME SO IT'S
BASICALLY BASED ON THAT
STATUTORY DEADLINE. FROM THE
BILL THREE YEARS AGO. AND IN
TERMS OF THIS SERVICE. THE
CONTENT OF IT. THE ETHNIC
STUDIES PARAMETERS CONTENT. IT
WOULD APPEAR THAT THERE. WHICH
A FAIR AMOUNT OF CONCERN OVER
THIS. IT WOULD APPEAR TO ME
THAT WE WOULD HAVE A LITTLE BIT
MORE IN DEPTH I WILL EVER HAD A
HEARING IN DEPTH ON THIS. ISSUE.
TWO I CAN'T SPEAK TODAY
HEARINGS IN OTHER COMMITTEES
I'M NOT FULLY AWARE BUT I WILL
SAY THE ONE KEY THING THAT THIS
BILL DIES IS A CREATES
ADDITIONAL TIME FOR THOSE
CONVERSATIONS TO TAKE
ADDITIONAL TIME YES BUT WE
DON'T KNOW IN WHAT FORM. THIS
ADDITIONAL SCRUTINY. WOULD
OCCUR IN THE IN THE POLICY
COMMITTEE I'M SURE IT WILL
BECAUSE IT WAS INITIATED TO A
POLICY BE ALSO WOULD BE THROUGH
THE POLICY COMMITTEE. WE'RE
JUST TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THIS
BUDGET TRAILER BILL TO TWEAK IT
TO ALLOW MORE TIME FOR THE
DELIBERATIONS. AND SO I THINK
IT WOULD BE PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITY THROUGH THE POLICY
COMMITTEE. ON THE FEWER MEMBERS
OF YOUR CAUCUS WOULD LIKE TO
ENGAGE IN THE CONVERSATION YOU
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY. I THINK
THAT CERTAINLY IS GOING TO BE
REQUIRED BUT I'M UNCOMFORTABLE
TO PROCEED AT THIS POINT. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
PUBLIC COMMENT. I'LL ENTERTAIN
A MOTION FROM OF OLD THANK YOU
THIRDLY THE MOVE BY THE POLICY
COMMITTEE CHAIR ACTUALLY. CALL
THE ROLL AB ONE FOURTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS MITCHELL HI
ANGEL AYE NIELSEN. WE ALSO KNOW
BELL WELL I CABALLERO. CAREER
AYE DALI DALI KNOW HER TAUGHT
OF HER TOTAL I'D JONES JONES NO
LEYVA. LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE MINING
MONEY NINE MORE LOCK PAN PAN
AYE ROTH ROTH AYE SKINNER
SKINNER AYE STERN STERN AYE
STONE AMBER AMBER GUY LIKE
HUSKY. WHY BECAUSE HE I BELIEVE
THAT ITEM OPEN ITEM FIVE AB.
ONE FIFTEEN MEDI CAL MANAGED
CARE ORGANIZATION PROVIDER.
FINANCE AS MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KNOW THAT THEIR PRE
EXISTING MANAGED CARE
ORGANIZATION TAX AND AB EXPIRED
AT THE END OF THE MOST RECENT
FISCAL YEAR JUNE THIRTIETH OF
TWENTY NINETEEN THIS BILL WOULD
ESTABLISH A MANAGED CARE
ORGANIZATION TAX EFFECTIVE JULY
FIRST AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
CURRENT FISCAL YEAR SO
RETROACTIVE AND IT WOULD GO FOR
THREE AND A HALF YEARS THE
EXPECTED REVENUE INCREASE FROM
ARE THE RESULT OF THIS BILL IS
ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
IN THE FIRST YEAR GROWING TO ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS TWO POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS. IN ORDER TO
HAVE THE TAX BE STARTING ON
JULY FIRST PAPERWORK HAS TO BE
SUBMITTED TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BY SEPTEMBER
THIRTIETH AND WE SHOULD NOTE AS
A MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE
DISCUSSED BEFORE THAT FEDERAL
APPROVAL OF THIS TAX IS NOT
CERTAIN BUT WE BELIEVE THAT
SUBMITTING IT BY SEPTEMBER
THIRTIETH AND THE WAY THAT THIS
PROPOSAL HAS BEEN DESIGNED WITH
INPUT FROM A NUMBER OF
STAKEHOLDERS OFFERS THE BEST
CHANCE OF FEDERAL APPROVAL THE
TAXES BASED ON CUMULATIVE
ENROLLMENT IN THE PLANS BOTH
PLANS REGULATED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE AS WELL AS MEDI CAL
PROGRAM PEOPLE CONTRA AGES I'M
SORRY IN SERVICE TO CONTRACT
WITH. DH CS AND IS BASED ON A
PER AND REALLY BASIS BASED ON
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN CAME WITH
AN ENROLLMENT AND OFFERS TAXES
BASED ON TEARS WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS TAX IS BEST DESIGNED TO
SURVIVE. ANY FEDERAL SCRUTINY
AND HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
QUESTIONS OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SENATOR NIELSEN. THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND-
HAS NOT HISTORICALLY BEEN A
REAL POWERFUL AGENCY WITH DISH
WOULD APPEAR TO ME TO GREATLY
EXPAND ITS POWERS AS WE ARE
DOING IN MANY CASES AGENCY BY
AGENCY YEAR BY YEAR BILL BY
BILL BUDGET BY BUDGET.
ACCORDING TO DIFFERENT AGENCIES
THE POWER. THE POWER TO. THE
LATTER INCREASED TAXES AND FEES.
AND THAT DOES NOT GO THROUGH A
NORMAL PROCESS OF DELIBERATION
IN THE BUDGET DELIBERATIONS.
THAT CONCERNS ME THIS IS BECOME
A HABIT. WHY WOULD WE WANT TO
GET HEALTH SERVICES THIS
AUTHORITY. SO ALL SPEAK BRIEFLY
AND THEN I'LL TURN OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER LAMB WHICH IS
THAT THE ACTUAL TAX OF COURSE
IS A FUNCTION OF THE
LEGISLATIVE ENACTMENT YOU MAY
BE REFERRING TO YOU WITH REGARD
TO OVER DO TAX AMOUNTS AND HOW
THOSE ARE HANDLED CERTAINLY
DEMONSTRATION WANTS TO MAKE
SURE IN A FAIR PROCESS THAT ALL
TAXES ARE PAID AND WILL TURN
OVER TO MISTER LAMB TO DISCUSS.
GEN ONE PART OF FINANCE WILL
NOTE THAT THIS IS EXTENDING
EXISTING TAX THAT IT'S
CURRENTLY ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. AND I'LL LEAVE IT AT
THAT FOR NOW. AND I WOULD ADD
EIGHT EIGHT EXTANT ATTACKS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE VOTED ON
SEVERAL YEARS AGO ONLY
ESTABLISH THE MCL TAX ON WOULD
FURTHER ADD. ON THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES
THAT MANAGES THE LARGEST
MEDICAID SYSTEM IN THE COUNTRY.
AND FURTHER THE MCO TAXES AND
REQUIRE ALL. A FEDERAL WAIVER
IS THAT CORRECT FEDERAL
APPROVAL YES THANK YOU DOCTOR
PAN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO THINK
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON
EXTENSION OF. THE MCO TAX WHICH
WILL ACTUALLY BRING IN MORE
MONEY TO STAY TO CALIFORNIA.
BRING IN MORE FEDERAL MATCHING
FUNDS TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR MEDI CAL
PROGRAM. I WOULD POINT OUT THAT
WE ARE A STILL A- DONOR STATE
WHEN IT COMES TO WE PAY MORE IN
FEDERAL TAXES OF CALIFORNIANS
THEN WE RECEIVED BACK FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THIS AGAIN
IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO. HELP
RIGHT THAT BALANCE TO BRING
MORE OF THOSE FUNDS THAT WE PAY
HIS TAXPAYERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BACK TO CALIFORNIA.
SO AGAIN. BUT DOES THEN AGAIN
WHAT THANK THE MINISTRY FOR
WORKING LEGISLATURE TO
SOMETHING THAT WE WANTED. AND
FACT AS CHAIR OF BUDGET SUB
THREE. OVERSEEING HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE BROUGHT UP
AND DISCUSSED IN OUR HEARING.
SO IT HAS BEEN HEARD THROUGH
THE BUDGET PROCESS AND I'M
PLEASED TO SEE THAT WE HAVE
COME TO A POINT WHERE. THERE'S
AGREEMENT THAT WE SHOULD EXTEND
THIS PARTICULAR. TAX I WOULD
ASSUME AND HOPE THAT. OUT WITH
THE REVENUES THAT THAT COME
FROM THIS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
ENJOYING FOR. MANY YEARS AGAIN.
IS SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
REINVEST INTO OF COURSE
INCREASING ACCESS AS WELL AS-
YOU KNOW THROUGH WHAT WE'VE
VOTED ON IN THE- MAIN BUDGET
THE VALUE BASED PURCHASING TO
LOOK AT WAYS WE CAN AND- ALSO
INVEST THIS MONEY TO. IMPROVE
QUALITY WHILE IMPROVING
EFFICIENCY AND ARE MEDI CAL.
PROGRAM IN IN OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM SO I. WANT. THANK
DEMONSTRATION FOR PUTTING THIS
TOGETHER SO THAT WE ARE NOW ON
THE SAME PAGE ON EXTENDING THIS
VERY IMPORTANT SOURCE OF
REVENUE FOR MEDICAID. OR
MEDICARE PROGRAM AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND BE SURE WE
USE THE FUNDS IN A WAY THAT
WILL. AGAIN THE XP CONTINUE TO
EXPAND THE EFFORTS WE'VE MADE
AN ACCESS FOR CALIFORNIA FOR
ALL. AND ALSO TO ALSO LOOK AT
HOW WE CAN BEND THE COST CURVE
AS WELL AS IMPROVED QUALITY.
LEVEL FOR PATIENTS ON MEDI CAL
FOR THE PARTICULAR COMES ROUND
CHRONIC DISEASE IN VALUE BASED
PURCHASING. ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS CENTER NIELSEN. LET
ME JUST KIND OF RUDE BUT THAT
THERE MAY BE SOME SUPPORT FOR
THIS I WILL STIPULATE TO RICH
BUT THERE IS ALSO SOME
OPPOSITION. TO THIS. AT LEAST
ON OUR SIDE OF THE AISLE.
LEGISLATIVELY THERE IS
OPPOSITION. THE EXPANSION OF
MEDI CAL. AND GIVING AN AGENCY
SO MORE UNILATERAL AUTHORITY.
TO DO THIS CREATES LONG TERM
FISCAL OBLIGATIONS. WHEN THE
ECONOMY IS STRONG. WE DO JUST
FINE. TOO MANY PEOPLE SEEM TO
BE FORGETTING WHEN WE WERE
TWENTY ONE NINE BILLION IN THE
RED AND FORTY FIVE BILLION IN
THE RED. AND A PREVIOUS BUDGET.
WHERE THERE WAS A BIT OF A
SURPLUS THAT MONEY WAS SPENT
PLUS. INCREASED OBLIGATIONS TO
THE FUTURE WERE BUILT IN. WE
ENDED UP. IN A HUGE. DEFICIT.
IN ONE GOVERNOR PAID A VERY
DEAR PRICE. ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. ARE WE
HAVE A MOTION PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS NICK LOUISE US ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS WE
LIKE TO THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION IN PARTICULAR
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
FOR THE S. SEVERAL MONTHS OF
DISCUSSION THAT WE HAD. WITH
RESPECT TO RESTRUCTURING THE
MCO TAX AND EXTENDING IT. THEY
TOOK OUR FEEDBACK SERIOUSLY AND
WE BELIEVE THAT WERE IN A GOOD
PLACE A WE SUPPORT THE EXISTING
STRUCTURE IN THE MODEL THAT'S
CONTAINED IN AB ONE FIFTEEN WE
ARE SEEKING A SIR SURE INCE'S
THAT IF THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES TO THE TAX IN THE
VEHICLE SHE SHINS DURING THE
WAIVER PROCESS THAT THOSE
CHANGES WOULD BE BROUGHT BACK
TO THE LEGISLATURE FOR
CONSIDERATION. AND DISPOSITION
ACCORDINGLY SO WITH THAT WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE MODEL AND
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE
HELPFUL TO HEAR FROM THE PLANS
NEXT WITNESS LINDA WAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE THAT BRINGS OVER. A
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY OVER
THREE YEARS IF THAT CAN. BE
USED BENEFIT LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AND
GT AS HE ON BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
MCO TAX EXTENSION WE ALSO LOOK
FORWARD AND HAVING. FOR THEIR
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
WITH REGARDS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS OF THE REVENUE
RAISED WITH THE TAX EXTENSION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. CAN MEMBERS KATHY
MUSTER WITH THE LOCAL HEALTH
PLANS OF CALIFORNIA WE WOULD
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM CAPTAIN WE DO
SUPPORT THE SENCILLO TAX WE DO
WANT TO ALSO THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION AND PARTICULARLY
DH CS AND- LEGISLATIVE STAFF.
FOR WORKING WITH US TO GET THE
LANGUAGE RIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. BUT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS BECAUSE SUPPORT
OF BLUE SHIELD OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE MCO
TAX IT AGAIN WOULD THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION AND- AND MEMBERS
FOR ALL THEIR HARD WORK. THANK
YOU LUCIA. GOOD MORNING RANDALL
COMING HERE BECAUSE BEHALF OF
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE FIFTEEN WHICH
WOULD REESTABLISH RENEWED THE
MCO TAX WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THEIR WORK AND
ALSO THE ADMINISTRATION.
HEALTHAXIS SUPPORTS THIS
REVENUE STREAM WHICH WILL
IMPROVE HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR
INDIVIDUALS IN THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM ALSO SHORING UP HEALTH
CARE DOLLARS TO MAKE THE
INNOVATIONS AND IMPROVEMENTS WE
NEED. IN MEDI CAL FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND WE HAVE A MOTION
CORRECT YES. THANK YOU PLEASE
CALL THE- FACILITY NIELSEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST AN
OBSERVATION AGAIN IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S GOES BEYOND
THIS PARTICULAR COMMITTEE AND
THIS PARTICULAR BILL. THERE'S
BEEN A SIGNIFICANT AND I'M
CHANGE I GUESS SEMANTICS NO
REALITY. FOR DECADES THE OLD
MANTRA WAS. TAX AND SPEND. AND
I'M WATCHING OVER THE YEARS A
CHANGE IN STATE GOVERNMENT WERE
WHICH- MISSION. TO NOW BE SPEND
AND TAX MEANING. OBLIGATIONS OF
FUNDING. IS VOTED BY THE BUDGET
BY THE LEGISLATURE. WHICH THEN
CREATES THE PRESSURE ON THE
LEGISLATURE TO FUND THE
EXPENDITURE SO NOW WE BECOME
SPEND. AND THEN TAX. AND PART
OF THAT DYNAMIC IS GIVING
AGENCIES. INCREDIBLE ABILITY.
TO IN FACT INCREASE FREEZE. THE
CHURCH EVEN TAXES. AND THAT
DOES NOT I THINK BRING WELL.
WITH THE TAXPAYERS WITH THE
CITIZENS. WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
PERSPECTIVE INTO CERTAINLY
HEARD IT BEFORE THE MOST OF
THEM THE ISSUE BEFORE US TODAY.
IN AB ONE FIFTEEN IS THE MCO
TAX WHICH QUITE FRANKLY IS A
DIFFERENT ANIMAL IF WE'RE GOING
TO FOCUS ON THE WAR TAX I
APPRECIATE. THE CONFUSION ALL
WE HAVE HEARD FROM THE HEALTH
PLANS TODAY WHO STEP FORWARD IN
SUPPORTING. THIS UNIQUE
SCENARIO BETWEEN HEALTH PLANS
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN THE
STATE. WITH THAT WE WILL OPEN
IT UP FOR ABOUT. AB ONE FIFTEEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS MITCHELL
HI MITCHELL AYE NIELSEN NIELSEN
NOBEL BILL I CABALLERO CAREER
ON A DOLLY DOLLY KNOW HER
DAUGHTER HER DAUGHTER I JONES
JONES NO LEYVA LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE MONEY MONEY NINE MORE
LOCK PAN. PAN AYE ROTH ROTH AYE
SKINNER SKINNER AYE STERN STERN
AYE STONE. STONE NO. BURKE
NUMBER GUY Y. KASKI BECAUSE HE
AYE. THE WHOLE THAT ITEM OPEN
MOVING TO ITEM SIX ON THE
AGENDA AB ONE SIXTEEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FINANCE. SO THIS
TRAILER BILL AB ONE SIXTEEN
REFERS SPECIFICALLY TO ENHANCED
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS ALSO KNOWN AS HE AYE
FTC'S CURRENTLY TO CREATE THESE
DISTRICTS THERE IS THE 55%
VOTER THRESHOLD FOR APPROVAL
BEFORE THE DISTRICTS CAN
ACTUALLY ISSUE THAT. AND WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS IT REMOVES
THAT THRESHOLD UNDER CERTAIN
CONSIDERATIONS WINDOWS OR MAC
SPECIFICALLY OF AN E. I. F. T.
THAT IS DESIRING TO. GO FOR
FINANCING PASSED TO HAVE THREE
PUBLIC HEARINGS THEY HAVE TO
GIVE NOTICE TO LANDOWNERS AND
OTHER RESIDENTS WITHIN THE I.
F. T. OF THOSE HEARINGS AND
THEN AFTER THOSE HEARINGS IF
MORE THAN FIFTY PER 50% OF THE
PEOPLE PROTEST IN THAT AREA.
DAN THAT HE I HAVE TO FINANCING
PLAN IS TERMINATED IF BETWEEN
TWENTY FIVE AND 50% OF THE
LANDOWNERS AND RESIDENTS
PROTEST THEN THEY WOULD HAVE AN
ELECTION AND THE I HAVE TO
FINANCING PLAN MUST BE APPROVED
BY THE VOTERS AND FEWER THAN
25% OF THE PEOPLE IN THAT AREA
PROTEST. THEN THE FINANCING
PLAN CAN MOVE FORWARD TO MAKE
SOME CHANGES TAX HOW THESE THE
I FD FINANCING PLANS ARE
APPROVED WHAT THE HOPE AND
PURPOSE THAT MORE THERE WILL BE
MORE BCI AFTER HE'S PROVIDING
LOCAL AND REGIONAL COORDINATION
FOR THE TYPES OF ISSUES THAT
THESE THE IRAQIS WERE DESIGNED
TO ADDRESS. IN ADDITION THIS
TRAILER BILL WOULD REQUIRE
ANNUAL FINANCIAL REPORTING FROM
THE AND HAS INTRODUCED
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS AND HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. ON QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIRD AVAIL.
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
ARE OFFERED THE REGIONAL I HAVE
THE I'VE D. BILL WHICH HAD. ON
VOTING REQUIREMENTS THIS BILL
DOES AWAY WITH THAT BUT IT DOES
AWAY WITH IT AND PUTS IN THE
STATUTE. SOME OF WHAT I
CONSIDER TO BE MESSY LANGUAGE.
FOR EXAMPLE THE OLD BILL HAD
REGISTERED VOTERS THIS BILL
SAYS RESIDENTS. I MEAN WHO WHO
IS A RESIDENT OF ANYBODY OVER
EIGHTEEN. SO IT'S MESSY THIS
BILL BILL HAD LAND OWNERS AND
IT BASS THE LAND OWNERS BASED
ON THE NUMBER OF ACRES THEY OWN
SO WE HAD LIKE A
PROPORTIONALITY IN TERMS OF.
THE SIZE OF THE PROPERTY A
PARCEL ON BY THE LANDLORD THIS
BILL HAS NO TO THOSE KIND OF
COMMENTS SO ESSENTIALLY WHAT IT
WHAT IT DOES IS IT GIVES THE
SAME NUMBER OF VOTES FOR OF A
RESIDENT THAT'S LIVING IN AN
APARTMENT. AS SOMEBODY OWNS A
PIECE OF PROPERTY THAT MIGHT BE
SIGNIFICANT I'VE I FIND THAT
KIND OF MESSY I THINK THAT'S.
SOMETHING THAT PROBABLY IN THE
FUTURE WE NEED TO CLEAN UP. IS
NOT PROPORTIONATE TO YOU KNOW
THE IS SAYS ANYBODY OVER
EIGHTEEN SO THEY DON'T HAVE TO
BE A REGISTERED VOTER YOU KNOW
HOW DO YOU DETERMINE WHO'S A
RESIDENT IN TERMS OF THE
PROTEST PROVISIONS SO IT
CREATES A- TO ME MESSY STANDARD
FOR ANYBODY TRYING TO CREATE
THESE WHICH TO ME MEANS THAT IT
WOULD LIMIT THE. ABILITY OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO USE THESE.
ENHANCE INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICTS I LIKE TO
SEE THIS LANGUAGE CLEANED UP.
WE SHOULD WORK ON IT I POINTED
THIS OUT TO PEOPLE THE BILL
WASN'T CHANGED BUT I INTEND TO.
CONTINUE TO WORK ON. OF TRYING
TO CLEAN UP THIS MESS THE
LANGUAGE IN THE FUTURE I THINK
IT HAS TO BE CLEANED UP TO MAKE
THESE. INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS MORE EFFECTIVE THE
ORIGINAL BILL. OF CREATED IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN WAS ONLY USE
BUT I THINKTHREE WE ONLY HAD
THREE SUCCESSFUL.
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS CREATED. AND I THINK
THIS MESSY LANGUAGE MIGHT
INHIBIT US. AND LIMIT ITS USE
IN TWO WEEKS WE CLEAN THIS UP
SO. I SUPPORT THIS TODAY I
THINK WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON CLEAN THIS UP. AND.
HOPE WE CAN GET SUPPORT FOR
DOING THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS SENATOR
NIELSEN. FATAL FAILURE NOW
TAKING CONTROL AWAY FROM THE
PEOPLE. I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES I SHARE IS CONCERNED
PROBABLY HAVE EVEN A GREATER
CONCERN ABOUT THAT. THIS SO
CALLED PROTEST PROVISIONS. IT'S
JUST AN EASY WAY OUT. IT'S AN
EASY WAY TO SAY WE DID
SOMETHING WHEN YOU REALLY DON'T
DO ANYTHING YOU DESCEND POWER.
DISENFRANCHISES THE VOTERS THE
CITIZENS THERE IS NO COST FOR
THAT. THESE DISTRICTS WERE
PROBLEMATIC. IN THE BE USED. IN
REMOVED. AND NOW THERE'S A
CREEPING WAY. TO BRING THEM
BACK. WITH I WOULD ARGUE EVEN
LESS ACCOUNTABILITY. THAN WE
EVER HAD BEFORE. ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SENATOR
STERN WE HAVE A MOTION VERY
GOOD I JUST WANT TO GET QUICK
COMMENT THERE I MY SENSE WAS
FROM CENTER BILL THAT IT'S
ACTUALLY QUITE THE OPPOSITE
EFFECT OF DIS EMPOWERING THAT
IT MAY BE OVER EMPOWERS THOSE
WHO DON'T HAVE A DIRECT STAKE
IN THE E. I. F. T. PROCESS JUST
WANNA GET A COMMENT FROM
FINANCE THERE IN TERMS OF
OPENNESS TO. MAKING THIS
FUNCTIONAL BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN
STALLED OUT PRINCES IN LOS
ANGELES FOR MANY YEARS TRYING
TO GET THE LA RIVER WHICH IS A
MULTI JURISDICTIONAL REGION
THAT NEEDS THIS KIND OF
DISTRICT TO BE COHESIVE IN
FINANCE SYMBOL AND WE THINK
THERE'S A PLAN TO DO THAT BUT-
WE GOT TO. SORT THROUGH SOME OF
THESE THINGS ARE JUST A QUICK
COMMENT SORT OF THE LABOR YES
SERVICE CENTER BILL HAD
MENTIONED THAT WE BELIEVE YOU
KNOW WE SAYS OF THE START OF
THIS YEAR THE DAD I SEEN
THEY'RE ONLY THREE E. I. ESTY
SET UP INFORMED AND SO PART OF
THE ADMINISTRATION'S CALL
WORKING WITH MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE IS TO GET MORE OF
THESE DISTRICTS FORMED IN
PLACES WHERE THEY ARE USEFUL
AND THE REASON WE PUT IN THESE
PROVISIONS ARE TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS SIMILAR TO THOSE OF
SENATOR NIELSEN. TO MAKE SURE
WHERE THERE IS COMMUNITY
OPPOSITION TO THESE TYPES OF
PROVISIONS THERE CAN BE A VOTE
OR IF IT'S MORE THE IF IT'S A
MORE IF IT'S A MAJORITY OF
VOTERS AND THE FINANCING LAN
DOES NOT MOVE FORWARD SO THAT'S
THE GOAL THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE IF THERE ARE IN THE
ENSUING YEAR BETTER WAYS OF
REACHING THAT GOAL AND MAKING
SURE CALIBRATION. IS RIGHT WE
ARE CERTAINLY OPEN TO THAT
CONVERSATION. PUBLIC COMMENT.
VENTURE MEMBERS MATTHEW HARD
WITH THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION ON THE
ONE SIDE REPRESENTING PROPERTY
OWNERS ON THE OTHER SIDE I'M
ALSO HERE TO REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FROM
LOCAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT WE'D
LIKE TO ASSOCIATE OURSELVES
WITH THE COMMENT ABOUT HOW WE
DO THINK THAT THIS LANGUAGE
HE'S TO BE TIGHTENED UP A
LITTLE BIT THESE DISTRICTS ARE
VERY USEFUL THEY'RE NOT THE
DISTRICTS OF THE PAST THREE
HEARD ABOUT ALL THE ABUSE I
LIVE IN WEST SACRAMENTO RIGHT
NOW WE PUT TOGETHER THE FIRST
THE I FD AND THE STATE IT WAS
VERY DIFFICULT. BUT IT'S A VERY
EXCELLENT THING THAT IS
PRODUCING VERY GOOD RESULTS ON
WEST SACRAMENTO SO AGAIN WE
LIKE TO SUPPORT SENATOR BELLS
COMMENTS ON THIS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AT TO TIGHTEN UP
THE LANGUAGE BOTH ON BEHALF OF
PROPERTY OWNERS AND ON BEHALF
OF THE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
FOLKS ARE USING THIS TOOL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL AB ONE SIXTEEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS MITCHELL BY MITCHELL
AYE NIELSEN NIELSEN NOBEL BILL
I COVER HERO CAREER AYE DOLLY
DOLLY KNOW HER DAUGHTER OF HER
TITLE I JONES JONES KNOWN LEYVA
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. MONEY MONEY
NINE MORE LOCK. PAN PAN AYE
ROTH. AYE SKINNER. AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN STERN AYE STONE.
STONE NO BURKE. NUMBER NINE
WHITE KASKI BUT BECAUSE THE AYE.
THANK YOU YEAH WILL HOLD THE
ITEM OPEN MOVING ON TO. ITEM
SEVEN ON THE AGENDA AB ONE
EIGHTEEN. STATE EMPLOYMENT
STATE BARGAINING UNITS. ONE TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE SEVEN ELEVEN
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
SEVENTEEN TWENTY AND TWENTY ONE
FINANCE THANK YOU SO AB ONE
EIGHTEEN REFERS TO AND USE AND
SPECIFICALLY WOULD RATIFY
CONTRACTS WITH THE BARGAINING
UNITS THAT THE CHAIR MENTION
PATEL MENTION ONE MORE TIME.
ONE TWO THREE FOUR FIVE SEVEN
ELEVEN THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN SEVENTEEN TWENTY AND
TWENTY ONE. THE CURRENT YOUR
COST IF ALL OF THESE WERE TO BE
RATIFIED AND FUNDING
APPROPRIATED WOULD BE A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND A
TOTAL OF ONE HUNDRED FORTY TWO
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS
INCLUDING ALL FINES AND WOULD
REMIND THAT FUNDS MUST BE
APPROPRIATED BY THE LEGISLATURE
BUT THIS IS SIMPLY RATIFYING
THE AMMO YOU WITH THESE
BARGAINING UNITS THE AGREEMENTS
INCLUDE SOME COMPENSATION
INCREASES AND OTHER BENEFITS
BUT THEY ALSO IN SOME CASES
INCLUDE GREATER EMPLOYEE
RETIREE CONTRIBUTIONS. I
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
ADDRESSING THE ISSUES WITH
THOSE COSTS THERE AND NUMBER OF
CREAM IS BEFORE YOU AND FINANCE
STAFF. HERE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
ABOUT THEM. COMMENTS FROM
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THAT ARE MORE LOT. THE
MANAGER JUST ONE QUICK QUESTION
ON THE CHP CONTRACT THERE WAS
AN ARTICLE ME SACRAMENTO BEE
THAT THEY WERE WILLING TO. CHIP
INTO THE PENSION SYSTEM AND I
DIDN'T SEE IT IN MY
COMMENTARIES IS THAT INCLUDED
IN THERE AND YOU. GRAY KIRTLE
WHAT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
YES THEY WILL BE CONTRIBUTING
MORE TOWARDS RETIREMENT DURING
THE TERM OF THIS CONTRACT. AS
PART OF ONE OF THE PROVISIONS
THEY'LL BE RE DIRECTING PART OF
THEIR STATUTORY SALARY SURVEY.
TOWARDS AN INCREASE RETIREMENT
CONTRIBUTION DURING THE TERM OF
THE CONTRACT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MANAGER. SAID AVAIL. WE
HAVE A MOTION. I SUPPORT THE
BILL. ARE THE PROPOSAL. I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT I THINK THE
IDEA OF HAVING DIFFERENTIAL PAY
FOR IN HIGH COST AREAS IS VERY
IMPORTANT. IN OUR AREA FOR
EXAMPLE WE CAN HIRE AND RETAIN.
PEOPLE TO CLEAN THE FREEWAYS IN
THE MAINTENANCE OF THE
FREEWAYS. THERE'S SO MANY
VACANCIES THAT OCCUR EVERY YEAR
BECAUSE PEOPLE FIND JOBS THAT
ARE PAID MORE. IN THE AREA AND
THEY HAVE THEIR- THEIR THEIR
SALARIES. ARE SO LOW COMPARED
TO. THE SALARIES IN THE AREA WE
CAN'T RETAIN PEOPLE AND AS A
RESULT OF FREEWAYS ARE A MESS.
AND WE HAVE A PROBLEM RETAINING
WORKERS IN IN OUR AREA FROM
FROM THE STATE. TO SERVICE.
PROVIDE SERVICE TO THE TO THE
COMMUNITY SO. SO THESE THESE
ISSUES ARE ARE REALLY A SERVICE
DELIVERY ISSUE. IN TERMS OF.
RETAINING EMPLOYEES IN CREATING.
THE PROPER ENVIRONMENT TO.
PROVIDE SERVICE TO FOR THE
PUBLIC AND IN. HIGH COST AREAS
SO. I SUPPORT THE PART OF THE-
THERE WAS A PART IN THAT I
THINK IT WAS THE US YEAH YOU
ONE THOUSAND CONTRACT. THAT HAD
DIFFERENTIAL FOR HIGH COST
AREAS I SUPPOSE THAT THANK YOU
ELECTRICITY THAT CONTINUE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
SEVENTY NIELSEN. I BELIEVE
THESE MO USE SHOULD MORE STAND
ON THEIR OWN. FACT PACKAGING
THEM UP HIS OLD BUSINESS BEEN
DONE A LONG TIME IT'S LEVERAGE.
SOME WILL LIKE SOME AND SOME
WILL NOT LIKE SOME. I THINK
IT'S A GREATER JUSTICE. TO
DIVIDE THE QUESTION AND
SEPARATE SOME OF THESE MO USE.
THAT'S SOMETHING I'M GOING TO
BE ASKING TO HAVE HAPPEN. ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS. SEEN NONE PUBLIC
COMMENT. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
NANCY VARIOUS WITH SEIU LOCAL
ONE THOUSAND REPRESENTING
NINETY SIX THOUSAND STATE
EMPLOYEES UP AND DOWN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA CLEANING NINE OF
THE BARGAINING UNITS THAT
YOU'RE VOTING ON TODAY JUST
ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THE
BILL THANK YOU. THE MORNING
AGAIN MADAM CHAIR JENNIFER
FEARING HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA WILDLIFE
OFFICERS FOUNDATION THE
CALIFORNIA FISHING GAME
MANAGERS AND SUPERVISORS
ASSOCIATION. DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE AND MOUNT LINE
FUNDACION WE WANT TO THANK THE
S. ELLIE A IN THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR NEGOTIATING
TERMS. IN THE BIãU SEVEN
CONTRACT THAT RECOGNIZE THE
SIGNIFICANT ROLE THAT WILDLIFE
OFFICERS PLAYING PROTECTING
CALIFORNIA'S EXTRAORDINARY
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WE ARE
DRIVE OUT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
BROOKS ALISON ON BEHALF OF CASE
BARGAINING UNIT TO THE STATE'S
ATTORNEYS AND JUDGES HERE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MATT CRIME IS ON BEHALF
OF THE OPERATING ENGINEERS
HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE EMMA YOU
FOR BARGAINING UNIT THIRTEEN.
THANK YOU AND YOU'RE WELCOME WE
HAVE A MOTION PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL IF YOU WANT A TO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS MITCHELL AYE
MITCHELL AYE NIELSEN. NIELSEN
NOBEL. BILL I CABALLERO. COVER
YOUR EYES DOLLY THE ONLY KNOWN
HER DAUGHTER. JONES JONES I
LEYVA. I'M MCGUIRE MONEY MONEY
NINE MORE LOG. PAN. I BROAD
ROTH AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE
STERN STERN AYE STONE. NUMBER.
NUMBER NINE WHITE KASKI BECAUSE
HE I. THE WHOLE THAT ITEM OPEN
TO ALLOW MEMBERS TO ADD ON
MOVING ON TO ITEM EIGHT AB ONE
TWENTY ONE SOCIAL SERVICES.
FINANCE IS THIS EIGHTY ONE
TWENTY ONE SOCIAL SERVICE I
WOULD JUST HIGHLIGHT TO CHANGES
BOTH OF THEM TECHNICAL IN
NATURE THE FIRST IS WITH REGARD
TO THE CAL WORKS TWELVE MONTHS
CONTINUOUS CHILD CARE THAT WAS
PART OF TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET
ACT THIS MAKES A NUMBER OF
TECHNICAL CHANGES INCLUDING
NOTICE OF LOCAL CHILDCARE
RESOURCE AND REFERRAL PROGRAM
MAKE SURE PEOPLE KNOW ABOUT
THOSE PROVIDERS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE AND THEN A SECOND
ITEM OF NOTE AND THIS BILL IS
REAPPROPRIATION ON SPANS TWENTY
SEVENTEEN FUNDING FOR THE H.
STAFF HOUSING DISABILITY AN
ADVOCATE AND ADVOCACY PROGRAMS
SO THOSE ARE TWO ITEMS OF NOTE
IN THIS BILL AND HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE. WE HAVE A MOTION
PUBLIC COMMENT. SEE NONE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AB ONE TWENTY
WHEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
MITCHELL AYE MITCHELL AYE
NIELSEN NIELSEN NO BILL. THE
LIFE OF A HERO CAREER ON A
DOLLY. HER TITLE. JONES JONES I
LEYVA FIVE LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
MONEY MONEY I MORE LOCK. PAN HI
CAN I ROTH AYE SKINNER SKINNER
AYE STERN STERN AYE STONE STONE
NO AMBERG. BY KASKI WHY BECAUSE
THE I. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO WAIT
FOR TWO MINUTES ALLOWING
MEMBERS TO COME JOIN US AND
WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE ROLL IN
THE OPEN ITEMS ONE MORE TIME.
TWO MINUTES. GET OUT OF HERE
.
BUT WE'RE GONNA OPEN THE ROLE
ONE TIME IF MEMBERS ARE HERE
THAT'S UNFORTUNATE WE WILL
START AT THE TOP OF THE AGENDA
WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE AB ONE OH
NINE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS JONES. JONES NO. STONE
STONE NO. THIRTEEN FOR THIRTEEN
FOR THE MEASURE KERRY'S AB ONE
TWELFTH STATE GOVERNMENT PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS JONES
JONES NO. STONE STONE NO.
THIRTY FOUR THIRTEEN FOR THE
MEASURE KYRIE'S AB ONE THIRTEEN
HOUSING PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MCGUIRE. STONE STONE NO.
TWELVE THREE TWELVE THREE THE
MEASURE KYRIE'S AB ONE FOURTEEN
EDUCATION FINANCE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MCGUIRE STONE
STONE NO. TWELVE FOUR TWELVE
FOR THE MEASURE KYRIE'S AB ONE
FIFTEEN THE MCO TAX PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS MCGUIRE.
TWELVE FOUR TWELVE FOR THE
MEASURE KERRY'S AB ONE SIXTEEN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CALLED THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MCGUIRE. TWELVE
FOUR TWELVE FOR THE MEASURE
KYRIE'S AB ONE EIGHTEEN STATE
BARGAINING UNITS PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS FURTADO. HER
TITLE I MCGUIRE. THIRTEEN TWO
THIRTEEN TO THE MEASURE KERRY'S
AB ONE TWENTY ONE SOCIAL
SERVICES PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS FURTADO. TITLE II
MCGUIRE. THIRTY TWO THIRTY TWO
THIRTEEN TO THE MEASURE KERRY'S
BUT DIDN'T FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE STANDS ADJOURNED